LeBron you set up for game one you were
anticipating some some differences in
Golden State in game two but what did
you find to be the most effective
whether Steph having the ball more the
way that they defended A.D what stood
out to you
um they made the adjustments and um you
know we knew we were going to do that um
that's what the championship team does
and uh you know they
they'll start when they're home for
tonight and we got a obviously see the
adjustments they make we got to make our
adjustments coming into game three in 80
just same question for you Draymond
started on your last game obviously it
was Looney they played a little
different on the other end as well with
the spread the spread offense how did
that impact you did you feel like
uh I don't think so I mean I took all
the same shots I took in game one uh you
know just missed them
um elbow jumpers uh pocket passes to the
floater same exact looks I didn't shoot
no shot that I didn't shoot in game one
I just missed them
um
that's all like Brian said they made
adjustments um
shot the ball extremely well from three
um
so we'll be better I'll be better
you know making those shots
get back home on a home for on our home
floor and uh try to take our business
these questions for either of you but
where did you feel like the game kind of
slipped away tonight was it the third
quarter when they you know made eight
threes and dropped 40 plus or was it
kind of right before halftime or what
did you see with that yeah I mean you're
going to have
um you know up 11 you know went on a run
and then obviously third quarter uh we
know they're a big third quarter team
came out on fire hit 43 in the third and
also 41 in the second so uh it's not
like us on a defensive end to give up
those
type of quarters
so we gotta be better defensively but
um I think you know going to halftime
you know when it made that run this kind
of you know we're kind of uh
you know got away from us you
know LeBron you've seen them go on crazy
runs in games
um in all your battles with them what's
sort of the key to
to not letting those build and stack and
and how do you kind of have to combat
that uh you got to keep scoring uh get
to the free-throw line
um as well or just get points in the
paint
going to go on runs that's what they do
you know but you got to keep scoring try
to hold the fort down obviously you know
but you give credible credits dude they
played exceptionally well it's a night
and we didn't
uh the series of tie one one so that's
where we're at what about you guys have
been one of the best defensive team in
the league over the last month plus
but the teams you played in the league
you know the wars are pretty unique the
way they play compared to the rest of
the league you know with their personnel
and continuing all that so what do you
think it will take to make your defense
shine as much as it has against this
specific team well we still are that
doesn't change we still want the best
defensive team in the league if not one
of them so that doesn't change and
that's what we hang our hats on
um but like I said you get credit with
creditors do clay with spectacular
tonight and Drake Mama's great in the
pocket pass with the roles and things of
that nature you know so Jermichael gave
him a big time and it's those you know
those 12 minutes felt like uh you know
24 minutes 30 minutes it was a big time
familiar for their team in the starting
roll tonight too so
you give a credit like I said what
credit is due and we move on to the next
game but our defense is where we that's
what we hang our hat and uh
and that doesn't stop no matter who
we're playing against
how did you how do you guys feel
obviously neither of you played in the
fourth quarter did you come out of this
thing all right and did you feel that
you contested their three-pointers
enough in this game obviously they're a
great shooting team but they made a lot
of threes
we feel great and we we did yes we
contested threes
80 when they go small obviously it
stretches
um the defense and you know gets
Shooters to the corners but
um does that change the way they were
able to defend you guys too with their
movement and and even though they were
smaller were they more did you feel like
they were more active in passing lanes
and things like that yeah I'll be there
a little bit more active in the uh in a
pocket
uh
you know they kind of clog the paint you
know in all pocket passes uh that were
pretty open game one and
um no it didn't help that we didn't
really shoot the ball well from three
um
you know so we start you know making
those shots making those threes uh be
tough for them to pull in and kind of
take away those pocket passes and US
planning to paint so
um that's all I think it was you know
they made an emphasis on making sure
that we try to they try to you know find
the guys on the perimeter
um you know on the three-point line and
clog the paint up a little bit